the United States and military is
leading efforts to help hurricane
survivors thousands of service members
including the Puerto Rican National
Guard are deployed to help people on the
island the military is going through
damaged streets and communities bringing
food water and medical supplies to those
in need
Omar Villafranca is in San Juan with an
inside look at the troops mission Omar
good morning good morning the USS
Kearsarge is just a few miles offshore
from here and we embedded with the
sailors and Marines from that ship their
mission helped restore vital
infrastructure to get this island back
up and running
the first Marines and sailors on the
ground in Puerto Rico came from the USS
Kearsarge these Marines have set up a
high-tech operation center on the island
we've been able to do is to find the
critical infrastructure find the nodes
where we can save the most lives if
necessary and and that's what we're here
for you Lieutenant Colonel Marcus Maine
says his Marines take those findings and
relay them to FEMA to help provide
assistance to devastated areas basically
how you're doing a Diagnostics on the
hospital we are and then emergency
response if necessary to save lives
many residents on the island don't have
running water so Marines are using a
filtration system to convert saltwater
to clean drinkable water it produces 150
gallons per hour
[Music]
the Marines have also spent the last
four days clearing trees and powerlines
from a road that leads to communication
towers that need to be fixed
Lieutenant Colonel Mane says the loss of
phone service on the island has made the
recovery process even harder the loss of
that infrastructure was actually more
devastating and you can imagine nobody
can get that life-saving aid that's
where we come in I mean that's our
expertise FEMA says only 25% of the
telecommunication systems on the island
are back up and running now cellphone
providers are here working on their
towers but more than a week after the
hurricane there is still no reliable way
to communicate on the island Gale Thank
You amar Thank You US military always on
time